[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui je suis fatigué j'étais
regarder dormir
et si ma voix peu apaisées je chanterai
pour toi toute l'année je t'entends dire
à tes pinko cyril je peux plus me passer
de lui et doit glisser sur ta peau c'est
comme si je te passer de l'huile et
s'ils ne sont pas nous c'est tant pis
pour eux s'ils le sont jalouses et en
paix pour fait le moi savoir quand c'est
douloureux je suis las il faut encaisser
pour nous deux et je le sais je te fais
confiance continue me souviens tu fais
pas semblant
j'ai pas besoin d'attendre plus
longtemps je sais qu'il est temps
partagé mon sens est élevé au rang de ré
or andré nault andré gt2 vo van der et
plein de rêves et rendrait et
[Applaudissements]